september council meeting of the world
council you can see that
everybody is here for what looks like a
very poor agenda
um there are no apologies
are there any declarations of
okay moving on into item
um three confirmations on the minutes of
the
um minutes and reports of the various
meetings
we've got the confirmation minutes
meeting council held
[Music]
the confirmation of the minutes in this
meeting
that we're about to confirm
i don't have clause 1 library upgrade
section the third
figure has
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
that is actually correct
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um is trying to
ensure that the meeting of record is
accurately correct
that that does not inhibit the council
from altering the recommendation from
the commission
[Music]
[Music]
the situation just needs to be noted
that the minutes of the administrative
community meeting
as presented to the last council
we're in the correct accurate record
so does everybody understand what's
canceled
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
it's just that we were having a
discussion
on premise that
the recommendation that came from the
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
the community strategy meeting as we go
to
the last council meeting and then
supported by
um
[Music]
getting the right record of matters that
were discussed
at the community
but it does have a fine effect to the
recommendation the councils that weren't
part of the meeting
[Music]
ratified those minutes based on the
information that's
been given so it becomes a little bit
safer
so this is what we do yeah
[Music]
um
okay so carrying on with
the rest of those minutes which will
recognize that
that operation do i have
some of this that is
[Music]
[Music]
in favor please say hi
[Music]
thank you councillors
so we have is there any urgent life
business
[Music]
it's not um
um
over the last year had a recommendation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay so it's open for discussion
classes
um nothing about the report but just to
note that
um quite it's very pleasing to see more
of the little
uh station doggy bags
around
[Music]
number of compared to compared to last
year
3374 as of june this year
i don't have that
and it's removed for a new home
does a school district council
[Music]
um are they capable by the new owners
whatever um where does that cost long
here it goes
um
uh
[Music]
um you will recall that last year we
made a
conscious decision to have a big
um clean up of the definition of
applications
amount
[Music]
um
okay there's no further discussions
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
discussion
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it
issues
[Music]
[Music]
however that that option has been
taken away from our residents in the
world
because of the changes to the water
plant
so in most other districts the use of
wasted world hasn't been able to be
used for probably many years and so
our south and regional residents have
been quite fortunate to
be able to use it for so long
it's it's it has been a very low cost
measure and it's probably the most cost
effective
um way of controlling dust um
apart from
in many other districts around the
country
including some of our recent post
neighbours
the council has over a period of time
and by various means um
they have either contributed part of the
cost
of um of appearing and sealing
a short section of road inside the house
or
this council
the council contribution
is likely to be
[Music]
is likely to be just providing the local
shield recipe
we would be intending to use some
councils
such as central cargo district also
use a a type of cell called
butter seals or some ecoseal
which is where the seal is basically
placed on the just on the gravel with
very very minimal
um preparation others other
councils um for instance
do a conventional two-part seal so i
haven't
um tied us down to using a particular
seal because
the the cost could vary so we don't want
to rule out
uh options that could be much better
to both council and the health service
[Music]
what sort of cost is it roughly for a
100 meter script
the cost
so the cost is approximately six
thousand dollars
um and that's for the household i mean
what the total cost
sort of averaged about twelve thousand
that's true so that
the total cost is around about 12 000
that may vary depending on topography
and
how far away it is but
they're likely to be in that sort of
facility
so some people applying they would sort
of want to get an estimate wouldn't it
because people should
be in for six or eight thousand per
household
to do it uh so
what they'd like you to do is
[Music]
[Music]
so that we can provide that to
prospective tenders for that
work to be done
questions to this one
i think this is
[Music]
well i think it's a good idea because
basically to get the oil um
or a vegetable contract around to do
it's about five thousand dollars and it
doesn't
last even a season i've had you know
four or five people
um probably had their wives just about
laying in me
and they wanted something done so this
is a good option
[Music]
okay so there's some recommendations um
the council
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rapidly um uh regulatory requirements as
well as
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you man
i think it's reasonably straightforward
it's probably still a little bit of a
refinement required
around
is
[Music]
as much renewal as you could on that
main water main engine across the main
road
but whether whether you do you try to
get that
after where the wickham street and then
try to use your lining technique under
the main road to
try to keep that pipe right for the next
50 years whether you could actually put
that into the budget and cut back a bit
on your inspections cost
because that main is pretty main one of
your main names and yellow blowing up in
the middle of the main road or the
railway
yeah certainly um that that section
where the main passes
under stabilizer
is a critical specifier
and could be potentially very expensive
to replace
the enlightenment piece of the network
so
a lot of the costumes associated with
establishment
um
i'm sorry i'll just add um since i've
put together the delivery plan
i've attended webinar last week um
around
what the what sort of information that
they're looking for in that delivery
plan
material and change the outcome but just
specifically
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
everywhere else will deal with the same
deterioration of the same type of
pipework
for the uninitiated yeah so i mean in an
ideal world we do the whole network
um but it costs a lot more
so i guess this is a bit of a compromise
that
if we don't do whatever's in the network
um we should now understand whether we
can
interpolate that data across the rest of
the network or
i guess if
[Music]
most critical
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um the criteria
of the money being allocated
and then that will give us an entire
view of that network and we know exactly
where our issues are
instead of going down the road of
allocating some of this money
towards we know we've got issues with
some of their mains running running
along those streets so
if we had an entire fantastic view of
the whole network then we know exactly
where we're heading
instead of just guessing it's not
guessing but you're saying 30 to 40
you know yeah i mean i think it's
probably something
that consider in the um
but um i think just a 30 percent
of the initial good start and then
if we complete that as well there's a
bit of uncertainty
the time trade the funding needs to be
spent
um potentially resource constraints and
things like that
um and you know
you might go and do it and then look
back and say well
[Music]
or
spending without allocating the rest of
the budget
or are you are you going to just do
600
essentially been spent on the living
street wastewater renewal
and i guess um then that
given what we now know about the
condition of that it's a very high
priority
so if you were to work or run into the
cctv inspection work
um you wouldn't need to find additional
funding to
replace that working street by school as
a matter of fact
um
thank you uh thank you man that's the
question
uh is this this required material or
discord
yes proportionally
years it's not long enough i'd rather
spend good money like for like
100 years i have heard stories of the
liners
collapsed chemicals
the outside of the pot that's lining has
collapsed
[Music]
for a hundred um and then the pipe
pipe life of 50 years it was realigned
that company's still going to be around
50 years to
get to validate their warranty so
yeah everything else yeah excellent but
yeah rehabilitate the existing
internal liner i wouldn't recommend it
i guess the server is going to tell us
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
there have been some technical issues
with providing i think i think
it's a relatively
um
okay um so we have a recommendation
there was somebody like to move that
recommendation
um
and just an update on that favorite uh
there's been not much um since last time
they didn't know their reputations would
have been received
[Music]
is
emergency management funding upgrade for
updates
emergency um agency we touch base again
at the end of
july um so then i'm really busy with
coco 19 but we had a great meeting
and went through what we spent today
so we thought that was really great um
any questions questions just
through the chair um
uni that money comes direct from the
government we don't pay levy or anything
to that
do we
where'd they come
oh
using
those costs are not covered but so
with the discussion with the people i
think i was signaled that we should
if there is a major project we should
engage a project manager so that there
is no stress on the staff
that is initials are just for
questions but we try to do it very
effectively
i think we should appreciate the team's
involvement and
taking management of the situation at
that time
any other questions or comments i
thought was something to move the
information you received
i think you just took the same type of
section today
[Music]
um
[Music]
just a couple of key things to draw
attention to
uh in terms of the way that uh
government is getting this to write
these new plans uh it's highlighted by
the number of chapters we're presently
having a list of plans 11
and we're going to end up with somewhere
between 15 and 56 chapters in our new
plan
and we will move from six zonings and
overlays to somewhere between 17 and 20.
so government's imposing upon us a far
more complex approach
in the past
[Music]
and at the last meeting i discussed with
the
committee whether it's worthwhile having
a
workshop
for councillors to update them on some
of the issues and
uh their response was maybe we should be
doing that in about february
uh um terms of a couple of work streams
that are underway um
an assessment has been carried out with
regard to orders of
included trees the district plan 100
something of them
um by an arborist
from uh christchurch which was
and his report the freedom government
committee that unfortunately
ian sober was not available with our
last meeting
and will consider that next meeting in
early october there is also work
currently underway in terms of
landscapes and biodiversity and they're
probably the two biggest
issues that we need to work our way
through
from the discussions that the
committee's been having have reached the
view that it would be helpful to have a
meeting perspective
uh coming through in some of these
issues so picking up on the resolution
of council from last year
is gone uh
that does not replace the formal
consultation under the act or the
consultation
with staff but together
as i said the keyword is a newbie
perspective early on
in the process public consultation
looking at undertaking with regard to
landscape
this year and two leading students in
public consultation in terms of
biodiversity we're running about six
weeks behind
where i expected to be at the stage for
a variety of reasons
that i've set out in the report there is
a paragraph at the end of the
report that i've just highlighted as
well
and that is the central threat that's
coming through from the thinking
of the committee is the recognition that
the cornerstone of the
plan is primary production and
associated processing
economic social and cultural viability
of the district
depends upon it notwithstanding the
primary production itself
must be undertaken in a sustainable
manner
happy to answer any questions and uh any
feedback from other communities
thank you um
committee members that would like to
just like comment on other processes
um i guess i made a comment
in relation to uh proposed workshop
you know it's quite a complex process
we're coming to grips with the
complexity of the requirements
single government direction we want to
take we've got a choice between very
very uh considerable very restrictive
and very
enabling us taking uh you know
in in after we've had another couple of
uh
topics to tackle and get our teeth into
we've all developed
an approach to the consistent approach
that we're comfortable with we keep we
[Music]
is what keeps this district going so we
want to in that respect
be quite
[Music]
move on into nzta funding assistance
right
um and that's all good news for us
[Music]
yeah thank you this was a pleasant
surprise a year
where some surprises haven't always been
pleasant
and it wasn't expected but i thought it
was going to be able to bring it to
accounts
potential not just in terms of
looking to save money but the
opportunist opens up to be able to
increase the level of service in some
areas where
we've had feedback from our annual
residents
and surveys that people might receive
for example
um so
rather than just quickly
suggesting how the money should be spent
my suggestion report is that we
come back to you with conservative
options
and for the council to do those and
arrive at a plan of attack
bear in mind we've got to decrease the
funding for the next three years
but our strong recommendation is our
existential investment
be maintained so that we can really get
a step change in the level of service
that we deliver to our opponents
okay open full discussion
it's not
[Music]
a good result and um i i can't work out
how
why they swing one way or them
[Music]
i'll try and work it out
yeah if you want to make
[Music]
some people
[Music]
of recommendation during the years the
farm dropped what was their response to
that in terms of
liberal service was it was it to reduce
it or was it to maintain a
ratepayer contribution um
[Music]
not so much so it just
just depends on what the council is
facing at the time
to be fair though it's been stable at 55
percent
for the
review but then now obviously convince
the
reviews
so there's no guarantee that it will
stay at that time in three years
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i was just wondering about the 19
vehicle incidents
it seems really it is but
the disposal parks department
[Music]
very much
[Music]
okay um
[Music]
is
um